six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the
five seven one area code who's that at
five seven one are you doing good who's
this it's curly
so quick thing I just wanted to let you
know for the pseudo-science
thing that you were doing yeah so I am
in taking nursing classes and sadly
enough there are some doctors that
practice this oil essential
pseudoscience yeah which I um I felt
like it was really difficult for me to
accept that because like that's in I
mean I don't know how to even feel it
and also I have like my nurse professors
critiquing the socialized medicine which
I have to bring it up with some fact
that thanks on your show I learned and
keep it keep it up with a little science
so wait Grover let me sit I want to make
sure I'm understanding how everything
you're saying you're saying that you
have there are physicians medical
doctors who are teaching your nursing
classes who are talking about using
essential oils as treatment for medical
conditions yeah like what which which
essential what do they say what
essential oils for which like I didn't
get a specific a specific on the topic
it was I think it was the oils what is
it I can have the water in my mind like
is it homeopathy or herbs well yeah
homeopathic exactly that one's exactly
that one so yeah are you available so
what school this is happening at do you
want to tell us uh I don't want to put
in about repetition but it's somewhere
in Maryland it's in Maryland and this is
a reddit institution yes it is it's a
college in Maryland I mean it's a Grover
if I may is it a for-profit institution
or is it a not a for-profit I think it's
a non-profit institution Wow but still
it was quite oppressing like how the
United States it's still living in those
five times yeah I'd want
to drop a class because I'm paying for
it I agree in there kind of skew in de
yeah and but I just have to go I'm just
doing that so I can get more money of
course and okay I packed my education
that's it I'm sorry it's extraordinarily
disturbing what you're telling me it is
yes it's good news I'm sorry it's bad
news my heart yeah it's bad news so keep
it up with that pseudoscience I really
hope that that thing you keep it up and
keep the funky dose to be homeopathy
videos and we will it's just a person
that they're teaching the nuns in
college or now it's yeah Grover thank
you appreciate the call always great to
hear from Grover